welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and wakanda forever just confirmed that
there is more vibranium in the MCU than
meets the eye when Ruby Williams
vibranium detector invention reveals the
existence of more vibranium deposits on
MCU Earth what if I told you that Marvel
Studios was hiding a huge piece of
vibranium right in front of our eyes
this entire time and that this secret
could help to explain a huge King the
Conqueror mystery that has been hanging
in the air since the Loki season 1
finale let us all explore just how
Marvel Studios has hidden vibranium
within the company's logo itself but
first do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today to find our
newest latest Obsession shirts inspired
by black panther wakanda forever look at
this shirt it's so beautiful but it's
not gonna last forever because beauty
doesn't last forever okay that's just
how life goes so by this shirt or others
like it today over at New
rockstarsmerch.com while they last
alright guys so if you're watching this
video that I'm assuming that you're
familiar with how every Marvel Studios
produce film since about like the first
Doctor Strange movie starts it's
basically iconic at this point you start
off with the flipping of comic book
pages and as we zoom out we then get
images of iconic Marvel Studios Heroes
followed by clips of iconic MCU moments
as we zoom out even further until
finally it is revealed that all of this
imagery was inside of the Marvel part of
the shiny metallic Marvel Studios logo
but while most people just assume that
Marvel Studios just opted to choose a
random metallic theme for their logo
after using a white logo in their old
Marvel Studios intro for years because I
am of the strong belief that this
material in the logo is Marvel's most
magnificent magic metal vibranium and
I'm going to walk you guys through why
this is the case and hey guys today's
video is sponsored by Babel one of the
top language learning apps in the world
I'm Gonna Be Seeing family over the
holidays which means a lot of food lots
of desserts and lots of pan Dulce from
the Panaderia in my hometown I'm tired
of being the guy pointing at the case of
pastries and drooling whenever I want to
grab dessert so I figured I'd pick up a
little bit of Spanish that's what Bible
is 4. Babel specializes in preparing you
for real-life encounters and situations
Studies have shown that 15 hours of
using Babel is the equivalent of a
semester of college Spanish and 15 hours
in Babel just flies by I can watch
videos listen to podcasts play games or
do lessons whatever kind of learning
mood that I'm in at the moment Babel's
got something that fits the bill and
like I really love how they gamify
learning and I have daily goals and
achievements that I can unlock as I
learn the language which is dope I'm
pretty early in my Babel Journey but I
have started to learn more useful
phrases like kiero comero todos Los
pastales which I do it's true true
statement get up to 60 off your
subscription when you click the link in
the description to start learning with
Babel today and we think Babel again for
sponsoring this video we've known ever
since our first introduction to
vibranium in the first Captain America
film that vibranium is a heavily
absorptive metal it's the main reason
why Steve Rogers didn't become Steve
swiss cheese Rogers when Peggy tried to
plug him with her piece after planting a
peck on World War II Natalie Dormer
foreign
defense it was Natalie Dormer and
vibranium of course also allows for the
Black Panthers Panther habit suit to be
able to absorb the kinetic energy that
it comes into contact with and release
it all at will in the form of this
purple light this is the Marvel Studio
concept that we're going to be working
with in this video by brain's ability to
absorb and store energy in all of its
forms walk with me now this is what we
are experiencing in the Marvel Studios
intro like all the heroes imagery and
moments that we see are supposed to
represent the collective energies of the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
specifically all the energies that have
collected up until the very point of the
current Marvel Studios project that we
are witnessing the Marvel Studios logo
in because as you're well aware the
Marvel Studios intro is constantly being
updated with more and more Marvel
Studios moments and heroes as the
universe continues to grow and the
reason why I believe Marvel Studios
decided to do this is to symbolically
represent how the actual universe of the
Marvel Cinematic universe is structure
and how is the Marvel Cinematic Universe
structured let's just ask our friendly
neighborhood big booty Judge Judy
erisham shall we our universe is a
constant exchange of energy
an infinite cycle of creation and
destruction but what are these energies
in this infinite cycle the infinity
stone energies of course energies that
we've known came with the big bang just
like the collector told us in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 1. these energies are
the colors that paint the entire canvas
of the MCU and is the very center of a
little something that I've coined the
Marvel trigger Theory a theory that I
developed a few months ago explaining
how all the glowing sources of colored
energy in the MCU ever since Iron Man 1
are tied to the rainbow of light that
enter the universe with the big bang and
each of these colors are tied to one of
the six key scientific foundations of
our universe reality power space time
mind and soul like the entire MCU has
been one big tale of all of these
infinity stone Big Bang energies which
is why director Hayward brought up the
concept of cmbr or Cosmic microwave
background radiation in one division my
equipment registered in extreme high
level of cmbr that's Relic radiation
dating back to the Big Bang yeah every
person every planet in every element and
moment that we have seen on screen in
the MCU has been created you using the
rainbow Big Bang light energies that
made up the same exact stuff the
Infinity Stones are made of like these
energies are the exact same thing which
is why Iron Man's Arc Reactor was made
from the space stone or like the
Bloodstone sucked man thing's life worse
like The Ether sucks Jane Foster's life
force this is why as the Marvel Studios
logo zooms out to reveal the key moments
that we've seen those moments are
colored with the Hue of one of the six
infinity stone energies and it's also
why each letter in the six-letter word
marvel briefly represent each infinity
stone energy color towards the end at
least at the beginning when Marvel
Studios first debuted this new vibranium
logo now what does this all have to do
with King the Conqueror and he who
remains and the Citadel at the end of
time you may be wondering well
considering what we've learned in
wakanda Forever about the planet Earth
having more than one vibranium meteor
having hit the surface at some point
during its development I believe that
the Citadel at the end of time is the
planet Earth well specifically all the
vibranium that was inside of the planet
Earth which would theoretically be the
only thing that is left of planet Earth
when all the light in the universe gets
sucked into the final black hole in the
universe at the end of time which is
what I believe we are seeing when we
zoom into this black hole on the right
in the Loki finale we are zooming into
Kang's home inside of this final black
hole at the end of time and these black
holes are part of a little something
called the black hole era of the
universe which is a scientific concept
which I've talked about in the past
video eventually the universe will
become just black holes that's all you
really need to know but anyways notice
how this massive rock that Loki and
Sylvia are standing on has a colorful
Aura and that The Light Within the rock
itself keeps changing into different
colors it's like a rainbow rock which
keeps fading in and out into different
colors this is because we're at the end
of time where all of those rainbow Big
Bang infinity stone energies get brought
back together when they've all gotten
sucked into the black hole at the end of
time and then gets sucked into the
vibranium rock at the center of the
black hole at the end of time this is a
scientific concept called the Big Crunch
which is is the opposite of the Big Bang
where all the energies of the universe
eventually come back together to form a
new Big Bang the cycle of the universe
this is why he who remains is regarded
as the god of the MCU because this is
all of the infinity stone energies in
one big old fish looking Rock and the
Rockler looks like a fish for some
reason I don't know why they did that it
just looks like a fish like he's
basically living on a giant Infinity
Gauntlet where the energies of
everything that has ever existed in the
universe swirl around it and slowly gets
sucked into the Rock and those energies
make up a sacred timeline it's all
gravity and black holes and [ __ ] man but
anyways this is the main significance
behind Marvel studios's vibranium logo
to symbolically show the paint colors
with which the entire MCU has been
painted with ever since 2008 and if
Infinity energy is the paint then King
the Conqueror has been Bob Ross this
entire time and boy is he coming to beat
the devil out of Scott Lang
just beat the devil at it but yeah that
basically it the Marvel Studios logo is
vibranium it has been vibranium ever
since 2016. but what do you guys think
of this discovery let us know in the
comment section below thank you guys so
much for spending time with me on this
video you can follow me at mastertonment
on Twitter if you want to see me tweet
some really weird [ __ ] so now I don't
know if Twitter's gonna be around but
more importantly you can follow new rock
stars wherever we are on the social
medias love you guys so much have a safe
holiday we'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
thank you